sister what is happening here
no no no no it is very cute it it is it
was agatha after all
kind of but exactly i mean okay big
night we're back we're here we are i'm
here
it is it's hot it's an emmy day yes
right right it feels back in business
and excited are you to be back with
folks and celebrating i know it's so
great i mean we were saying we hadn't
had a wrap party so this is the first
time we're gonna have to we're gonna see
each other since we've shot the show
it's been like two years so it's crazy
the whole cast is nominated i mean
it's so exciting we put so much
love into that show and it was such a
meaningful chapter of my life making it
so just the fact that we're all here is
so crazy well the chapter's not closed
for you i mean who knows they run listen
they're on a real tight ship yeah we
have no idea
you're learning you're learning the mcu
quickly i don't know nothing i don't
know nothing
right exactly it's all encrypted
how much fun are we gonna have tonight
how much are we gonna party i mean i
hope a little bit
i mean i haven't gotten the high heels
on in a million years i know i hope so
how many carrots do we have on our neck
tonight this is beautiful i don't even
know
terrified of it who is it beautiful i
think it's dip oh should know that it's
okay okay but it's gorgeous it's
gorgeous and this jumpsuit yeah lavon
it's pretty good yes it's it's really
really fun you're always so fashion
forward you really are jackets are
coming back
agatha's deep agatha's d
i mean look at you
look at you
look at you look at that
look at that
this man i love it i love that
i know
i love it
i mean he's just got 20 nominations
under this belt for his show that's it
just 20 nominations tonight
thanks you guys thank you